Оплатити проїзд у наземному транспорті банківською карткою чи електронним квитком,
знати час його прибуття з точністю до хвилини,
а замість звичних маршруток пересісти у нові комфортні автобуси.
Для більшості українських містян це поки що мрія.
Натомість у Житомирі завдяки зусиллям молодих реформаторів
це почало ставати реальністю ще у 2017 році.
Місто стало першим в Україні і навіть одним із перших у Європі,
де в муніципальному транспорті запровадили валідатори
і термінали для безготівкового розрахунку за квитки.
На першому етапі валідатори з’явилися в кондукторів.
Ці валідатори всю готівкову виручку почали реєструвати.
Ми вже побачили весь пасажиропотік, зокрема скільки і на яких маршрутах взагалі їздять люди.
І насправді це рішення дозволило нам
проаналізувати і змінити принцип організації транспортної роботи.
Очоливши у 2015 році комунальне підприємство "Житомиртранспорт",
активіст Іван Фурлет разом з однодумцями взявся докорінно реформувати міський транспорт.
Вперше за 10 років капітально відремонтували понад 20 тролейбусів,
побудували для них дві додаткові лінії. До того ж, закупили 17 нових автобусів.
Дмитро Ткачук пояснює:  зробили ставку на комунальний транспорт,
аби максимально замінити ним традиційні маршрутки.
Купивши комунальні автобуси, які обладнані кондиціонером,
в яких встановлено валідатори, в яких кожному видавався квиток,
в яких чітко перші поїхали за розкладом, в яких запровадили посадку через передні двері,
оплату у водія і все інше, а не передавання коштів через весь салон.
На цих прикладах ми намагалися розвіяти ті міфи.
Коли казали, що це неможливо, а маршрутка такою завжди була і буде.
Тобто ми показали, що це можливо.
Аби зробити громадський транспорт привабливішим,
Дмитро Ткачук з колегами взялися за оптимізацію руху з урахуванням потреб пасажирів:
збільшили кількість поїздок громадського транспорту у години-пік,
а пенсіонерам дали право на пільговий проїзд лише в найменш завантажені години.
Аби пасажири мали точний розклад руху, міський транспорт обладнали GPS-трекерами.
На нових сучасних зупинках з’явилися табло з інформацією про час прибуття
автобусів і тролейбусів.
Приватних перевізників міська рада теж зобов’язала встановити GPS-трекери.
Мені зручніше пересуватись містом, я економлю час,
знаю заздалегідь, коли буде маршрутка.
Також мінус те, що не всі маршрутки обладнані датчиками, не всі показують в дорозі, лише частина.
Є варіанти, є альтернатива.
Хочеш, чекай тролейбус, хочеш сідай в маршрутку,
але оці маленькі маршрутки, вони вже мені у більшості своїй не до вподоби.
Мені вже зручніше саме в таких автобусах громадського транспорту.
Їх ще не дуже багато, але вони більш комфортні.
Ще на початку реформи мерія намагалася об’єднати комунальний транспорт і приватні маршрутки
в єдину систему з прозорою оплатою проїзду,
компенсацією проїзду пільговиків і високими стандартами сервісу.
За майже чотири роки зробити це так і не вдалося.
До прикладу, у грудні 2017-го приватні перевізники Житомира спочатку погодилися
встановити у салонах термінали оплати проїзду карткою та видачі квитків тим, хто платить готівкою.
Проте вже через півроку відмовилися від такого формату роботи.
У житомирській мерії підрахували:
для ефективної роботи безготівкової оплати має бути щонайменше 60%,
адже гроші передані за проїзд водієві маршрутки практично не можна відслідкувати і порахувати.
Часто недоотримують їх навіть власники цих мікроавтобусів.
Експерт з питань транспорту Олександр Кава .
пояснює, в подібній ситуації опиняються майже всі українські міста
Міста не не можуть відмовитися від маршруток.
Вони не хочуть відмовитися через корупційні зв’язки,
які існують між приватними перевізниками,
які як правило не сплачують податки або мінімалізують податки,
та чиновниками місцевих органів влади.
Нині, за даними місцевої влади, кількість маршруток у Житомирі скоротилася приблизно на 23 відсотки.
Деякими вулицями курсують тільки міські автобуси й тролейбуси.
Водночас повністю обійтися без маршруток місто поки ще не в змозі.
Розуміючи це, приватні перевізники вимагають від мерії підвищення вартості проїзду вдвічі
і компенсацію за перевезення пільговиків.
Конкуренція є, але їх не так багато тих машин.
Зрозуміло, що вони нові і вони забрали якогось пасажира.
Це однозначно.
То в нас виходить, що в день 300-400 людей їдуть безкоштовно на одній машині.
Якщо це порахувати, то виходить кругла цифра, додати ці гроші, то нема питань.
Наразі лише на запровадження безготівкового розрахунку у громадському транспорті
житомирська міська влада витратила майже 20 мільйонів гривень.
От-тільки 80% пасажирів досі продовжують оплачувати проїзд  звичним способом -
готівкою кондуктору чи водієві. Безготівковий розрахунок не надто популярний.
Мало, мало (платять картками) 5 чоловік, 10 чоловік може бути.
Це найбільше буває, що 10, а так не дуже багато.
В принципі талончика так само відриваєш,
просто, що приклали карточку і не береш нічого, зайвих дій не робиш.
Переконувати пасажирів у доцільності безготівкової оплати квитків у Житомирі
планують за допомогою знижок.
Уже з наступного року проїзд для тих, хто  користується електронними квитком
чи платить банківською карткою планують зробити на 1-2 гривні дешевшим,
ніж для пасажирів з готівкою.
Плани були більш зжаті в сроках.
Ми вважали, що то все можна зробити швидше і рухатися масштабніше.
Але реалії вони трошки пригальмовували.
Ми на старті розуміли, що скільки б не вдалося нам зробити, важливо змінити фундамент.
Треба змінити сам принцип замовлення взагалі цих-от послуг.
Своїм напрацюваннями молоді житомирські чиновники охоче діляться з владою інших міст.
Спираючись на їхній досвід, безготівковий розрахунок у наземному транспорті
запровадили у Вінниці, Чернігові, Луцьку та Харкові.